اذا تمكنت امهات الدول المختلفه من
الاجتماع سويا فلن يكون هناك المزيد من
الحروب مقوله للكاتب البريطاني في احدى
رواياته التي صدرت عام 1910 الام هي الام
وان تعددت الثقافات واختلفت الاشكال
والطبقات الاجتماعيه ومر الزمن ولغه الحب
واحده من جنوب افريقيا الى اقصى سيبيريا
الامهات بطلات خارقات يقمن باصعب عمل على
وجه الارض بكل الشغف والدفء ومنتهى الحنان
الدوام اليومي على مدار العام دون رواتب
وبلا عطلات سنويه ولا حتى اجازات نهايه
الاسبوع تختلف تواريخ الاحتفال بعيد الام
من مكان لاخر وفي العالم العربي يحتفل
الناس بامهاتهم في الحادي والعشرين من كل
مارس اول ايام فصل الربيع هي فكره الصحفي
المصري الراحل علي امين وتحدث عنها لاول
مره في مقال عام 1955
على كل حال زميلتنا ندى حجازي اجرت تجربه
اجتماعيه مع الامهات في الشارع
تقرير مؤثر مليء بالمشاعر فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
يا حبيبتي ربنا يخليك ولادك بكره بكره
كل سنه وانت طيبه يعني
يا حبيبه
هتجيبوا ايه
ما عندكيش كده طلبات كده
معينه في عيد الام
هديتك في الدنيا كل سنه وانت طيبه كل سنه
وانتم طيبين والورده الاخيره لمامتي كل
سنه وانت ورده حياتي يا ماما بما انك ام
شو ممكن تحكي لنا عن هذا اليوم المميز
للامهات والله يعني ما اريد اقول لك شيء
بس هو فعلا كل يوم هو عيد ام يعني الاولاد
احلى نعمه بالدنيا يعني هم احلى هديه
واحلى نعمه والله يحفظ اولاد العالم جميعا
يا رب طيب كيف انت يعني كام بدنا نرجع
لموضوع عيد الام انه كيف بتقدري تنسقي
وتكوني على نفس درجه الحب بين ابنائك
هو دائما يعني في الحب الاول والحب الاخير
فدائما اول طفل هو اللي يجعلك ام تكون
العلاقه به غير يعني مو علاقه امومه يكون
علاقه وطن خلينا نقول بس
الصغير هو يحبب نفسه دائما فيعني تختلف